[Music]
once upon a time there was a mighty king
it was said he ruled over a small island
off the coast of Sardinia many had
searched far and wide for the lost king
but still no one had fat weight in it
that's him that's the king then they
know t even leather me I used a ladder a
me enorme upon your birth or you oniy
fed up to become a doorway right Tony
you know all my stuff his family has
lived on the island for over 200 years
his great-great-grandfather Giuseppe
Berta Leone arrived on the uninhabited
island in 1807
the king of Sardinia Carlo Alberto was
well intrigued
so if invitato Josep Alberto Leone Ave
do we need a catch a key at Table Rock
eternal quest a cappella Salvati dented
or alaykum o don't sit call t see the
vision tu assemble a Casillas not
appropriate when a rat sada Caprica al
Kunihiko no Kiseki annual speech there
became an indication of a presence a
photo cartridge Epoque es posible Ava
arranged Edisto a Punto hello Minerva
ready tewara
humble yet escrito a but leone coat of
arms were painted flags were made and a
royal family tree was drawn news had
even reached Queen Victoria who sent a
photographer to photograph the new royal
family tellin Coralie
about in kampala mr. photo coverage in
article an accomplished an abdominal
solicited who died in the life of his
lordship oh gee well ok for cheerio
you know sport perm a pas de pesca me
divert aqueous cassava channel over ET
labora a restaurant arizona mark bye
a ruler with a restaurant are you really
a king yummy tank I thought I defeated
Rey Rey come here ambient an ad he
O'Meara tango foundation dented array
the Queen DC Camilla prima Moscow train
the simple T Telecom - araignee auntie
hey Tatiana
if I personally Tanya hello I'm already
on the table 14 annuities on post over
my face tapasya propio Bassanio macaron
Majesty I totally agree
[Music]
seven miles off Estonia's west coast in
Eastern Europe lies the small island of
canoe a bucolic and serene place that
feels lost in time home to just 400
people it functions like one of the
world's few matriarchal societies this
is a place where women roll well mostly
everything my name is Mariah anitha's I
lived almost all my life in this island
our lifestyle is different comparing the
lifestyle in the mainland many old
traditions fill our lives one such
tradition is that canoes men spend
months away at sea fishing for the
island meanwhile canoes women are in
charge of leading the community and
preserving its way of life
men were always wrong time away from the
island and something the historical
reason why women become a very strong
very independent kid no conscience
interesting because we have killed where
additional costumes as I everyday
wearing she's making skirts because she
has five granddaughters we have ancient
folk songs still alive and dances they
have a lot of practical skills how to
live all over the year here yes life is
more difficult here to survive it's
treasure for 1000 islanders they all
described island that it's like a
paradise it's the best place in the
world we hadn't made let off camera era
an image in her go to her in the ring
gear I got rocked again nice and
employee said Kittleman amis in new a
lot of justice quicker start up a leak
on mostly the clothes
the music the dancing all of it has been
recognized by UNESCO on its intangible
cultural heritage list the keynote
rating songs and many traditions are
more than 2000 years old so this is the
main thing why we are in this UNESCO
List
the same list acknowledges canoes women
as the custodians of their islands
heritage I concern everybody about our
unique culture can disappear it's very
valuable if those things still exist and
survived and the modern world it's
really miracle
[Music]
life on the island is new easy and it's
not place where you come to get rich but
it's a better lifestyle so it's a
happier lifestyle
we're so few people in Ireland everybody
has to have multiple jobs to keep they
under foot where everybody else
[Music]
welcome to North Franzi a small remote
island off the northern reaches of
Scotland home to around 50 people two
lighthouses an airport some sheep cattle
and a few seals and that's about it
not much of a labor force so while on
the mainland you might have one maybe
two jobs up here it's more like six or
seven meet Sarah Moore my name is Sarah
Moore quite a few jobs in Islands I'm
the homecare Clark to the community
council I work at the airfield
I catch and load a firefighter I got
flock of sheep I'm the poster Island
really the job has been an Islander
which is just mucking in and helping
with various bits and pieces and not two
days everyone the same I could be
helping but cattle one day and fixing
our roof the other day and it's whatever
they violet does need help be just
mucking Logan 727 north nice jobs here
when there's one eight four degrees
safety is a number one priority and no
sauce here thankfully we've never had an
emergency so hopefully keep it that way
I moved to the island a bit three and a
half years ago Phaedra I wasn't enjoying
life there and there's just so many
people and you get any can anybody
you're completely anonymous it's quite a
lonely place up here my confidence is
gained massively because people they
come along the teach you the skills that
you need I certainly never had sheep at
Edinburgh hello most people didn't quite
understand that when I see I've got like
six jobs it's not six full-time jobs I
mean it starts off from working you know
24 hours a day
there's for my job satisfaction at the
end of it
you can see if I accomplished something
as opposed to just you know done the
same old thing D&D I think it's
something like 25 houses in Ireland that
I deliver to a few hours it depends on
they might have post forget this island
is really magical I mean it's completely
unique in its own way you're never going
to find a place like this where you can
just come up and live the way you're
supposed to live you know the rule by
the weather is supposed to the clock and
I have no plans to go anywhere I'm
setting up roots and gonna be here till
I die
[Music]
what do you say to people who just say
this is not a normal way of them thank
you very much
[Music]
I'm Katherine and this is my husband
Wayne I'm Wayne and welcome to freedom
code
[Music]
we live in a secluded Cove the only
options we have to get here is by water
there are no road accesses the water is
our highway everything that you see here
in our home is floating
we are tied to shore with lines we are
not anchored we have our main living
house we have the dance floor
the lighthouse building for green houses
as I started to grow the garden and make
it larger than we had to have more space
for that garden everything is done with
a handsaw and hammer no power tools I
know every board and nail by name
it's about 500 tons a million pounds and
I'm flowing I've been building tree fort
since I was seven and I said well dad
I'm putting the tree fort in the ocean
no when I go town again Lansing mm-hmm
the thing about living in Clack would
sound on the west coast of Vancouver
Island it's the richest biomass owner so
the opportunity to fish for dinner is
big
I just get in my canoe and paddle out in
ten minutes I can catch a fish when it's
windy into too rough out there I lay on
the coach or fish out of the house I was
hoping to make a lot more money as an
artist so subsistence living was our
only opportunity to have anything as
artists we could never buy real estate
so we had to make our own it was a great
opportunity to actually move away from
the city to see if we could prosper out
here
now 24 years later we're still doing it
I can't imagine living any other way I
feel completely fulfilled oh that's good
[Music]
a two hour boat ride off the coast of
Colombia is an island the most densely
populated island on earth
[Music]
santa cruz del is latte consists of more
than 1,200 people living on land the
size of two soccer fields making it four
times as dense as manhattan on the
island is a school that runs up to the
tenth grade two shops and one restaurant
there is nurse steady supply of water
and a Seoul generator that only runs for
five hours per day there are no police
but there isn't much need for them as
everyone on the islands knows each other
a hundred and fifty years ago the island
was primarily uninhabited and was
sometimes used by local fishermen as a
place to rest and take shelter during
storms gradually some fishermen came to
build their homes here these were the
grandparents and great-grandparents of
the current generation of residents
despite the close living quarters
inhabitants on the island say they
wouldn't give up their peaceful
existence for anything not even a little
more room
[Music]